irenne Chag propose voyage sans
passeport
île de rêve l'Atlantide des Caraïbes
voici Haïti en créole Haïti veut dire
pays de haute montagne aussi est à 1700
m que vous ferez sa connaissance en
commençant par porte au prince sa
capitale qui compte un demiillion
d'habitants au pied de cette colline se
niche des villas et des hôtels plus
beaux les uns que les
autres
au fil de notre promenade en bordure de
la route un comb groupe de terrassiers
qui ryth leur travail par la noblesse de
leur geste de leur champ fier pendant
des heures il travaillent
ainsi
près de cette caille c'est ainsi que
s'appelle une maison à CRÉO un vieux
pressoir bois de la canne à sucre dont
le jus donnera un r
excellent à quelques kilomètres du Cap
Haïtien qu'on appelait autrefois le
Paris des Antilles par la vie brillante
que les colones menaient se trouve la
petite ville de M bâti en contrebas des
ruines de l'extraordinaire palais royal
de sans souci construit par par les
ordres du Roi Christophe ancien
aubergiste du Cap que toute une vie
d'aventure et de courage porta au cimes
de la
gloire ce château qui était la résidence
du roi Christophe fut malheureusement
détruit par un grand tremblement de
terre puis par un petit sentier muletier
nous grimpons tout en haut du mont du
bonnet de l'évêque où se trouve la
prodigieuse citadelle Laferrière comme
dans un compte de fé elle apparaîtra
soudain attirante et mystérieuse il faut
grimper durant des heures pour y
parvenir
mais l'air est doux et embaumé par le
parfum des fleurs qui s'incline sur
notre passage et qu'on appelle les
madames jolies ou les cœurs d'amour tant
elles sont
belles nous arrivons enfin au pied de
cette fameuse citadelle construite en
1804 et achevée en 1817 pour résister
aux troupes françaises qui en définitive
ne l'ont jamais attaqué toutes les
pierres 360 canons et des milliers de
boulets y furent montés à dos d'homme ou
sur des aessieux en acajou le Roi
Christophe yidor de son dernier sommeil
lorsque cet être extraordinaire a pris
la défaite de waterlo il s'écria devant
tous ses officiers comment as-tu pu
survivre à une telle défaite tu n'es
plus digne de figurer dans ma galerie
des héros et il lacerra le portrait de
Napoléon son plus grand ennemi sa FA fut
tragique apprenant qu'il était trahi par
ses troupes se tira une balle mais une
balle en or dans le
cœur chaque lundi d'un lieu appelé le
châteler des fleurs sont cuillis
Marguerite souci et glaol pour être
vendu au marché de la ville tous ces
paysans sont venus de 20 km à la
ronde
mon oh
mon à côté du marché central les h de
porpr
mon
et sur les hauteurs se trouve le
quartier résidentiel des riches
porprci l'air est plus frais et les
piscines sont pendant les grandes
chaleurs de l'été moins un luxe qu'une
nécessité
chérie
maman
pas
Mang et celle que Chau petits indigèn
avec une eau moins limpide est aussi
savoureuse
accompagné du murmur de la rivière
froide ainsi appel lav ch Bab se raconte
des histoires au milieu d'une bonne
humeur
communicative
au port de La Saline les bateaux vont et
viennent transportant indigènees et
marchandises vers le nord ou vers le
sud non il ne porte pas tous ses
chapeaux sur sa tête par souci
d'élégance c'est un marchand chapeau du
reste vous vous en doutiez un peu
d'ombre permet de vendre des mangues
fruit les plus délicieux de
Haïti et une voile de bateau de
raccommoder les
filets en guise de diversion il faut
organiser une chasse au CA dans les EAU
somatres DE l'étan de la
hutete après 3h ils arrivent sur les
lieux ils sont équipés de fusil de
guerre des spitfiels et accompagnés d'
sous-officiers de l'armée car ils vont
tirer dans la partie du lac limitrophe à
la République de
Saint-Domingue al faut être
prudent et pend ce temps les femmes
indigènes passent plisiblement au beau
milieu de
l'ét paraît qu'elles empreintent
quotidiennement ce chemin
voilà en fin de journée ils ont tué
trois caill et récolté quelques bons
souvenirs ce qui est tout aussi
agréable un des derniers survivant de la
préhistoire vient du fond des temps pour
vous
saluer
c'est impressionnant
non et puis soudain les tambours des
Caraïbes brisent le calme de ce paradis
Haïti chante Haïti danse c'est le
sourire des Grandes Antilles le rythme
s'accentue et la joie
éclate
ado
babaa
M
m
angangang
mangangang Yee Yesu Yee Yesu Yee
Yesu
Mango mundango ye
IR vous a proposé voyage sans passeport
cette émission a été réalisée pour
montage avec René gar et Christian de
Murg son gérardener Michel dur
scriptequel noir illustration sonore
Dominique paladil réalisation Solange
p